Lulu Lulu Oh hold on hold on one second
alert alert that's what you sound like
are you happy now mirror is clean let's
begin the challenge the rule is simple
get the do for Laura do okay my name new
shove in my name let's go to measure
spreading oh that's great that's great I
know this I have atomizer spray a my own
ironically cleaning there was just punch
in the screen
why is all about okay with this and not
the gay right wedding so disappointing I
know K looking more mall Burmese just
what we needed
I've seen the footage you owe me god
damn it what is this picture
I love it brofist if you're gay - come
on gauge the rest have to wait for a
hundred mil but the real gay bros you
get the fist now what can I say I'm just
inclusive like that but only gay people
it's the mic that bad oh god does he
have one of the blue Yeti mics they're
worse than my microphones
yeah it's no it sounds great I swear to
God it is the blue Yeti isn't it it only
works if you're in this an isolated room
right yeah people love it for some
reason it's such a piece of hunt it's a
hundred-pound microphone and it sounds
awful all right you want this kind of
microphone this is sound bad I can't
tell it all right so far no stuff that
we're doing pretty good brofist it know
how he kept a straight face how still
some fans didn't get the memo table ox
14 years at 19 Willard joins us now live
from South Seminole about the car did
how fans are dealing with their
disappointment tonight okay well
throughout the evening cardi B fans who
rolled up here the El Paso County
Coliseum went from feeling good I didn't
got that very good why does cardi B
exist she's so annoying and I hate her
listen don't judge me I need to clean
new space there's smudges everywhere got
to make sorry guys got the made shirts
clean otherwise I will get 500,000
comments about how my mitt there's a
spot there isn't it where there there is
it here then I get it did I get it next
time I clean your face okay don't think
I will do it mother-fricker sneak Sarah
oh I've seen this I'm laughing even
though
it's so good I love that boom that comes
in the middle as well
it's a beautiful editing ten out of ten
I miss dark souls such an epic game too
bad I'm not a nerdy gamer anymore
dummy nerdy game it's it's him again
excuse E is that real
yeah is that a chicken oh god I laugh at
the worse
all right moving on oh god it's about to
get worse
stop this guy just keep making these
type of clips now is he milking this for
the memes okay I respect it will you
give me blood jab smile equals yes
bladder equals no salt so bad it's a
simple spell but quite unbreakable could
you guys please careful with your words
because my parents are right Nick plain
how does everyone have such a good
internet no crime
8 a.m. 6 p.m. well boys we did it behind
between 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. is no more
incredible what does that mean I swear
I've seen these signs what is it no
crime sign me does that actually mean no
crime no crime sign what is this what
does that mean
is it Photoshop take that criminals
alright well so far zero Scott that good
job to me
about these goddamn Bart Simpson I
respect the edit but I will not Scott
that I really really enjoy setups that
are just instead of like debouncing this
here it's like because then you require
both the mobile app and the web app to
implement the search function that way
and if I ever want hack element about
sisters it's so awkward mom go away I'm
streaming lamb okay all right I'll cool
down I'll call them sorry the
monetization but I'll put it away
have I missed a spot did I miss anywhere
on the mirror up here is there a spot
here okay I clean you laugh you clean
the mirror how much I love these oh god
I want to laugh how am i sucked I want
to laugh well that means you get a
sprite
got him is it me or is it
oh all right that's one that's what oh
my god I miss Wendy G and case I was
friends it was the best I love their
content now they just hate each other
and don't love each other it make me sad
please help me give too much beauty
Oh God it hurts when you want to laugh
and you don't and I didn't laugh which
means you get spritz that's why you get
splits big what happened to this show I
don't know it's the first time we ever
do this oh god I laughed God Eric I
didn't even realize okay where do I
clean tell me where it's dirty and I
clean it now I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
Senor I will make a cleaner is this a
racist joke I think it kind of it's and
it's really problematic how you didn't
call me out on it what's your deal if
you enable the humor and just stand
aside then you're equally bad if not
worse and I want you to write an apology
in the comments down below and until
I've seen it smash like on this video
oh god damn it I laugh afterwards so he
doesn't count okay that means you get
[ __ ] what type of girl my girl the
pastel goth no flag Asian no tiny girl
now
oh look at that we brought back the old
quality of the videos is it bad does it
okay it's fine no not these no don't do
it oh I wouldn't freak mini but I would
god damn it
okay it's cleaning time where do you
want it where you wanna clean all right
I give up i forfeit it's time to end
this thank you guys for watching my
channel thank you for subscribing this
is the last episode check out merch you
know it's fun right I'm not supposed to
give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price